mario and the rabbids blast off for a
galactic adventure in the latest mario
plus rabbids game
space is in a universe of trouble when
other worldly enemies suddenly appear
their goal
take the energy possessed by sparks
these mysterious creatures
now our heroes must set out to save them
a new adventure of epic proportions
awaits
you'll initiate a turn-based battle when
you encounter an enemy
before we begin here's something you
ought to know
you can freely move around the
battlefield as much as you'd like within
your character's range before using
their weapon
pretty neat huh
let's start with mario
three enemies are in the way so let's
dash into one of them
[Music]
now select rabid rosalina and have her
dash into another
[Music]
next rabid luigi
one more dash and now disruptor time
by using a dash first then the weapon
three enemies were wiped out with that
his turn is over
back to mario
let's take out the other two
pew pew
that concludes his turn
last but not least rabid rosalina team
up with an ally and jump
get positioned then finish off with the
kaboomer
okay our turn's over
and now the enemy attacks be sure to
take cover and you might be safe
if you don't it won't be pretty
alright we've got the floor again
dash toward the bomb
and if you chuck it over
boom
that'll do it
the key to victory is how you assemble
your team and navigate around the
battlefield
wait is that bowser and he's joining the
team
mario plus rabbids sparks of hope
rockets on to nintendo switch october
20th pre-orders begin today on nintendo
eshop
check out ubisoft's special showcase
tomorrow for more details about mario
plus rabbids sparks of hope
[Music]